in pokemon sword and shield your journey
isn't quite over when the credits roll
you still have some fun surprises in
store
a legendary to catch a whole postgame
quest to embark on we put together a
list of everything you should and can do
when you finish the game to make the
most of your goal Aryan Adventure the
postgame quest once the credits are over
and you reload the game you'll be at
your house in post WIC where professor
Magnolia will give you a master ball
once you have that head outside and turn
left to go into the slumbering Weald and
travel all the way to the very back
where you found the rusted sword and
shield earlier hop will be there and
this will kick off the quest all you
have to do from here is follow Sonya's
instructions which will take you to each
of the gyms aside from spike myths to do
some hero stuff and catch Ethier's ah
Shion or Zama Zenta plus you get to
fight these dorks rare league cards
during the postgame quest you'll collect
some rare alternate league cards for
various characters you'll have to go out
of your way to get some of them though
to get Marni's you have to go to spike
month and beat her in a Pokemon battle
she'll be right outside the Pokemon
Center there to get roses find Oleanna
in the gallery mine you can get leon's
by battling in the battle tower which
I'll get to in a bit and you can even
get one from the ball guy outside moto
stoke gym catch more Pokemon in the wild
area once you're the champion every
pokemon in the wild area will be above
level 60 and of course you can capture
all the powerful Pokemon you've yet to
catch try doing raids too if you haven't
in a while the five star ones are super
hard but you can get some excellent
Pokemon from them
gift Pokemon number one make sure you
stop by hops house and go upstairs to
Leon's room you'll find a poker ball on
the floor containing a Charmander that
will be able to Giganta max just like
Leon's Charizard it also has some
perfect stats gift Pokemon number two
you can now go to the battle tower which
is located in windin it's easy to just
fly there once inside go to the left
where you'll see a league staff member
with a Pokemon called type null this
staff member will give you type null and
all the items you need to make the most
of it the battle tower BP while you're
there you can try your hand at the
battle tower
instead of experience points the battle
tower
netsy battle points or BP which can be
used to purchase battle related items
these include the new mints which can be
used to change a pokemons nature there
are two BP vendors on the left in the
battle tower plus a BP shop in the main
hammerlock Pokemon Center you can only
earn BP in the battle tower and there
are some items you can only buy with BP
so be sure to check out what's for sale
and what you might need the battle tower
renting on the right there's a man who
will rent teams to you this is a great
way to get started at the battle tower
without fussing with a team of your own
or worrying about which Pokemon are good
he has five teams available for rent
three singles teams and two doubles
teams I recommend starting with the rain
team for double battles because it's
much easier to use in the slow team and
the skill team for singles the battle
tower battling you can use rented teams
your party or teams you register from
your boxes for battle tower matches for
double battles you bring six Pokemon but
only select four for single battles you
bring six and select three you can
either return to the entrance after
every battle to switch up your teams or
you can keep going until you lose you'll
be kicked out from time to time as you
level up in the ranks at which point
you'll get rewards like extra BP mints
and rare candies getting the judge
function Sun and Moon introduced one of
the best features for competitive
players the judge function it allows you
to view a pokemons base stats in the PCU
displayed in various degrees from no
good to best sword and shields judge
function is even easier to use you still
have to go into the Pokemon boxes but
rather than click into a Pokemon summary
and toggle it from there you can toggle
the judge function on while scrolling
through the boxes to more easily find
the hide stat Pokemon you're looking for
to unlock the judge function you just
have to win 6 battles and either singles
or doubles in the battle tower hyper
training also in the battle tower
there's a guy who will hyper train your
Pokemon for you all you need is a level
100 Pokemon and some bottle caps which
you can buy at the BP shop in the battle
tower for 1 bottle cap this guy will max
out one base stat of your level 100
Pokemon it's a surface level change so
it won't affect the stats of Pokemon you
breed with this pokemon for example but
it will improve its performance in
battle it's worth doing if your Pokemon
is almost perfect
charms aside from the battle tower there
are two people you definitely want to
talk to in the postgame and both are at
the hotel in sir Chester head to the
building on the left and go up in the
elevator
the first is behind the second door from
the end defeat him in battle to get an
oval charm which increases your chances
of finding eggs at the nursery when
breeding pokémon the second person is
behind the last door and he'll ask you
to come back when you complete the
pokédex like in previous games he'll
give you a shiny charm which increases
your chances of finding shiny pokemon
those are the main things you should do
when you beat pokemon sword or shield if
you're interested in battling
competitively keep an eye out for our
QuickStart guide to breeding training
and assembling a good competitive team
coming soon and for more on pokémon
sword and shield stay tuned to game spot
[Music]
sweet